we got to talk about this Andy yes I
I've tried I think in the last couple of
years since I got the show we've been on
the air almost five years I have tried
very hard to become I think a pretty
good performer in some respects oh well
you you seem to be I was not asking for
that applause although two of you the
fact that only two of you seem to agree
hurt me turbine I went there for a
reason
I'll tell you why I have tried
[Music]
no Andy I any I bring this up for a
reason it's that I bring it up because I
have I think I tell the mean little joke
I do the little talking with people
write the interviews that's my that's
the universal sign for celebrity
interview and I do the comedy sketches I
think I do a lot of a stuff they really
strive to be a well-rounded showman
thank you and my point is that I was
thinking about the other day and I
thought you know what to really be a
great showman to be one of the all-time
great people in show business one of the
great all-time performers you really got
to know how to dance that's something
that I never learned how to do and I
think that's the one thing the fact that
I can't dance is the one thing it's
keeping me from becoming a great showman
it's been holding me back for years I
know and I thought I can't help you
right but maybe what I can do maybe what
I can do is maybe in one day if I signed
up for a lot of the great dance classes
here in New York City and there are many
this is the capital of dance in America
if I sign up for some great dance
classes I could take them all in one day
and learn all the important styles of
dance so ladies and gentlemen I did that
just a few days ago I went out and I
learned every conceivable form of dance
that I can think of in New York City and
I brought a camera crew with me and
ladies and gentlemen this is what I
discovered later would you roll this
please
this is the Joffrey Ballet School in
Greenwich Village and trying to go check
it out let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you get up on your toe is that oh
you don't do that you just go into half
point half points and okay just put your
feet in first position okay what's that
this is this position okay okay like
this okay all right all right all right
well then don't turn them out so much
turn them in a little bit more how about
that that's just a pro painful well then
you shouldn't be doing this
[Music]
[Applause]
look you should have you should have a
look of like hey I can do this in you
can
okay thank you I'll work on the movement
later just the face I work on now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're at Paul Pella Kouros DanceSport
on the Upper West Side this is Paul how
are you you know going in you taught al
pacino how to do the tango in Scent of a
Woman is that right that's my claim to
fame what I really want you to do is
teach me how to dance like Al Pacino
well first of all we need a blindfold we
got to make you look blind because he
was blind in that character so but is
this what he used to train this is the
exact scarf
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Kelvin he's a hip-hop instructor
that right what do you think of my
threads and they're pretty cool just a
pop yeah that's pretty good
is this authentic looking I mean this is
is this street yeah the pants are really
baggy I got something they need to be
baggy and maybe a little lower lower
you're kidding right No okay well that's
like you can't get technically much
lower than that or it's a whole
different kind of show we're doing show
me just how we get started here do those
guys find the beat once the music start
you gotta find the beat and the way you
do that just keeping these loose get a
loose for the bounce anything we can do
you know you're not okay cuz if I can
moonwalk I know that I'll be right on
the cutting edge of what people doing
right now
this is 1986 right I want to show you
something if you get more time imagine
there's an invisible thread hanging off
each hip joint all right
wet the fingers come on don't be shy
grab one thread pull it up grab the
other thread pull it up and do a hip-hop
beat
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now I I kept the outfit to the hip-hop
outfit very nice I'm gonna start
bringing a little of that look into this
show right yeah okay all right folks I'm
gonna take a break when we come back
Thane Maynard is gonna join us